TO GET VACCINATED.
>> I WILL
THANK MOG NEWS WE ARE IGHTTBIDE
NOW. I STORY WITH OUR
POLITIT'R
IS ON,EV.ING ABOUT TION?
>> A I THAT GOES
BACK TO 2018 WENDERSTAND
THAT RECENT MONTHS, THE
INVESTING TO PT
OF THE JTIT
GOVEINITICALNS.
THERE WAS AN EFFORT TO MAKE SUR,
BIDEN NOW ELECTED PRESIDENT, THE
U.S.NEARE
INFORMED THE AGENTS WORKING ONHE
STATEMSAYS, IN PART, I
LEARNED YESTERDAY FOR THE FIRST
TIME THAT THE U.SOFFICE IN DAR .
I TAK VERYSERIOUSLY CONFIDE A P
F
MATTERON I
AAPPROPRIATELY, INCLUDINGHNEFI
ADVISERS.  ONDING FROM DOING T
W MYSELF AND P
BROW IS IWHO CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATIONWE A AHE PROSECUTO
DEWANG AT AMBTHINGSNC
HUNTER
P OR NOT THOSE
ACTIVITIES AERING WS THE TOKING
INCOME WAS REPORTED RECTLY
LAST -- OVER A NUMBER >>ND'RE A
LEARNINGGOESGA
OF ADIAMOND, ANDTHATDLY TO
ER BIDENNCHINA.
US ABOS RIGHT.WOLF, ATH 2017.
HUNT SOME OF
THIS IN A"NE
PUBLISHE LYEAR.
HE SAID AT THE END O  THISBUSIN
AT MTIIS RM 2.8
CARATNOWHAT HAPPENEDDIAMOND.ACC
HUNTER BIDEN PROVIDED TOHE
NEDO SOME ASSOCIAT A DOESN'T KNN
LOOKING SPECIFLY THE
TREATMENT OF
PURPOSES.
OBVIOUYES GIFT
TAX WHICH, YOU KNOW, WE DPPENED
THE WAY, HR BIDOR O TAXBUT W K
THE CURIOUS THAION HAS BEENATUNE
IS G T COOPERATEIT
INVESTIGATIONE HAD  ADVICE OF T
IN A OFRSLL
SET T N B
ADMINISTRATION WHICH PROMIS
LEADUSMENT ALO A  DEPART DOES I
HEY HANDLE TORISSUE.
INVESTIGATION,
I WANT TO  PRECISE. ECT. IS A IN
BE HAN THERSCRIMINAL INVESTIGAT
DELAWARE, T ACTED?
>> Reporter: WE HAVEN'T HEARD
SPECIFICALLYRO THE
PRESIDENT-ELECT.
BUT HISNSITION TEAM DID
RELEASE A STATEME THAT
OUBIDEN'S
STATEMENT.
I WANT TO REA YOU WHAT ITSAYS.I
BIDEN IS DEEPLHIS
WHOAS FOUGHT INCLU T VICIOUSRSO
NT
THE THATRENCING WERE THE PRESIDT
ERE ARE STILL QUENS A ONE O THO
HUNTER WASINVESTIO
THAT HIS TAX AFF WERE BEING
JUST LEARNED
THIS ERDAY.
A STILL TR WHA
EXACTLY THAT TIME WAS FSIDENT
THISWELL.
BU EVAN'S REPORTINGAS
NOTED THE PRESIDELE
IMINVEE
GOINWARD WHA
REACTION LIKE AS THIS
IN CONTINUES AND HOW INTO POTEN
HIS ADMINISTRATION A B
VOWED THAT HISAR WILL
>>NO MATTERTHE PRESIDENT-ELECTI
HISTY  OFFICIALLY NONARIN- LEAD
DE SAY
LLOYD AUSTINOR
ROLE?RESIDENT-ELECTIDPOKE
TO PERNAHIP
THAT HAS HAD WITH
GENERALTIN WHO HE HAS
CHOSEN TO BE H DEFENSE
SECRETARY.
HE POINTED B THEIR WORK EN WAS
IN THE MILIRY LEADERSHIP
HE WILL BRING
ONE BIG HURDLE IN ALL THIS ISSTL
ROM DO
THE RULE THAOMNE TO BE
OUT OF ACTIVE MILITARY SHEY CAN
NS JUST RETIRED FM
MILITARY FOUR YEARS AGO SEDEMOC
EX CONCSM ABOUT
GRANTING HIM A FAVOR.
LISTEN.
YOREFRIEND I WANT TO
THANK YO  SPP TO SE
THIS IS N A HE B
SOTIN RETIR FROM THE RY SERVICE.
BUT THEAWS THAT A
OFFICER MUST HAVE L
SERVICE SEVEN YEA
BECOMITA R LT
I FULLY UNDERSTDCT
AND I W BEING IFID NOTEV IN
HISTORY DIDN'T CALL FOR DOES CAR
IT.
r: AUSTIN ALSO
EXPRESSED A COMMITMENT TOOL OF H